♪ ♪
>> Greg: SO, YOU REALIZE THIS
WON’T STOP.
THERE ARE MILLIONS OF ARRESTS
MADE EVERY YEAR.
THE ODDS THAT A DOZEN OR SO WILL
END UP HORRIBLY, 100%.
ALL IT TAKES IS ONE VIDEO TO SET
IT UP, AND OF COURSE THE MEDIA
THAT INFLAMES IT.
THE VIDEOS ARE SHOCKING.
WHAT UNITES THEM ARE THE
VISUALS.
WHAT MAKES THEM DIFFERENT ARE
THE STORIES BEHIND THEM.
THE DEATH OF GEORGE FLOYD AND
TONY SHARE COMMON TRAITS.
BUT THEY ARE DIFFERENT RACES,
WHICH CHANGES HOW IT’S COVERED.
SHOULD IT?
THE STATS BACK UP WHAT I SAID
AFTER THE FLOYD KILLINGS.
BAD TRAINING, UNBENDING MINDS.
AND NOW IT’S COUNTERED WITH AN
EQUALLY UNBENDING RAGE NOW
STEERING A COUNTRY TOWARDS RUIN.
ALL IT TAKES IS ANOTHER VIDEO.
IS THERE SOMETHING THE MEDIA CAN
DO TO SAVE US?
YEAH, STOP PUSHING INFLAMMATORY
UNINFORMED OPINIONS.
THE MEDIA SHOULD GET A ROOM AND
READ THE STATS OF POLICE
INTERACTIONS AND KNOW EVERY
SINGLE MISTAKE SHOWN IN THESE
VIDEOS.
ALL RACES INCLUDED.
THE CULPRITS ARE ACTUALLY BAD
TACTICS IN TRAINING.
THE RACE CARD FADES WHEN YOU SEE
HOW MANY WHITES ARE KILLED AND
THAT NONWHITE POLICE ARE MORE
LIKELY TO SHOOT NONWHITE
SUSPECTS.
IT’S TIME TO TAKE THE FOOT OFF
THE RACE PUDDLE AND PLACE IT ON
TRAINING AND TACTICS SO REAL
REFORM CAN BE MADE, SO THE.
CHICAGO HAS HAD 18 MURDERS IN
24 HOURS.
THE MOST VIOLENT IN THAT CITY IN
60 YEARS.
WHO DO YOU THINK THE VICTIMS
WERE?
SO MEDIA PEERS, WHY DON’T WE ALL
HAD TO A CONFERENCE ROOM AND
FACE THE FACTS, LITERALLY?
>> Dana: [LAUGHS]
>> Greg: SO, DANA, THE MEDIA
HAS A ABSOLUTELY NO IDEA HOW TO
POLICE ITSELF AND IT COMES TO A
YET THEY DEMAND, THEY BELIEVE
THAT THEY CAN POLICE THE POLICE.
THIS REALLY FRIGHTENS ME.
>> Dana: SO, FIRST OF ALL, I
WANT TO KNOW IF YOU ARE GOING TO
HAVE PASTRIES IN THE ROOM AT THE
HOLIDAY INN EXPRESS.
IF SO, WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE
ARE THERE.
>> Greg: I KNOW THAT JUAN
LOVES HIS SWEETS.
>> Dana: HE DOES.
I DO THINK THAT WE KNOW THAT THE
MEDIA DOES FOLLOW STORIES LIKE
THIS.
AND ESPECIALLY IF THERE IS,
RIGHT?
BUT I ALSO THINK THAT THERE IS
ANOTHER ANGLE HERE, AND THAT IS
THE SOCIAL MEDIA ANGLE.
AND THAT IS ALSO, I THINK,
FUELING THINGS.
MAYBE EVEN THE TRADITIONAL MEDIA
DOESN’T UNDERSTAND OR SEE.
I THINK THEY ARE LATE TO IT.
THAT’S ONE OF THE THINGS YOU
HEARD FROM THE PROTESTERS.
WE’VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS
FOR YEARS.
IT TOOK A VIDEO FOR YOU TO
BELIEVE US.
NOW COME ON THE GOOD NEWS IS
SIDE OF THINGS, THE THINGS YOU
MENTIONED IN TERMS OF TRAINING
AND TACTICS, IN THE LEGISLATION
THAT SENATOR TIM SCOTT HAS BEEN
WORKING ON, AND I THINK THERE’S
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON IT, THEY
HAVE THINGS LIKE DEALING WITH
ACCOUNTABILITY, TRAINING,
TRANSPARENCY, DE-ESCALATION
ISSUES.
THOSE TYPES OF CONCRETE THINGS
THAT PERHAPS, IF WE ALL FOCUS ON
GETTING THIS LEGISLATION ACROSS
THE FINISH LINE, WE WOULD HAVE
DONE A GOOD SERVICE FOR THE
COUNTRY.
>> Greg: JUAN, IT SEEMS LIKE
WHENEVER I TURN ON CNN, THEY ARE
TRYING TO INCITE A RACE WAR.
IT’S SOMETHING THAT THEY ARE
PROFIT CENTERED.
IT’S VERY DISTURBING.
>> Juan: WELL, I HOPE THERE IS
NO RACE WERE COMING.
I JUST WANT TO RESPOND TO WHAT
YOU WERE SAYING, BECAUSE I FOUND
IT INTERESTING, GREG.
TO MY MIND, I THINK THAT WHAT WE
HAVE IS, I SAID THIS TO YOU
BEFORE.
I THINK THE POLICE UNIONS, A LOT
OF THOSE CONTRACTS THAT THE
POLITICIANS SIGN ONTO ARE REALLY
THE ROOT CAUSE HERE.
THEY PROTECT BAD POLICE
OFFICERS.
I DON’T THINK THAT IS IN
ANYBODY’S INTEREST.
I THINK WE SHOULD NOT HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE A GUY LEADING ON
HIS NECK HAD REPEATED COMPLAINTS
COMPLAINTS.
NOT ONLY BACK ON THE FORCE, HE’S
BACK ON THE STREET.
WE HEARD THIS FROM THE
MINNEAPOLIS CHIEF, ET CETERA.
I THINK IT’S IMPORTANT TO
HIGHLIGHT, BECAUSE I THINK
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN IGNORED IN
TERMS OF PREVIDEO COMPLAINTS
ABOUT ABUSIVE POLICE BEHAVIOR,
IF THEY SEE THAT IN FACT THE
MEDIA REFLECTS THE REALITY, THEY
FEEL BETTER AND THEY FEEL LIKE
YOU KNOW WHAT?
SOCIETY IS RESPONDING.
THE POWER STRUCTURE WILL
RESPOND.
THAT’S HOW YOU GET CHANGE.
THAT’S HOW YOU GET REFORM.
THE BEST OF MEDIA IS WHEN MEDIA,
AS THEY SAY, YOU KNOW, AFFLICTS
THE COMFORTABLE AND COMFORTS THE
AFFLICTED.
RAISED A RUCKUS, LET PEOPLE SEE
WHAT’S GOING ON, AND LET’S HAVE
REFORM.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT.
I AGREE WITH THE REFORM.
IF WE WERE LIVE ON THESE VIDEOS
WITHOUT CONTEXT OF THE FACTS,
THIS WILL NEVER END.
IF WE ONLY CHOOSE SPECIFIC
INCIDENTS AND OVERLOOK OTHERS,
LIKE THE TONIES OF THE WORLD,
YOU’RE GOING TO GET A DISTORTED
VIEW OF A REALITY.
>> THAT’S WHAT I WAS TALKING
ABOUT EARLIER, IS HOW WELL-
WELL-EQUIPPED POLICE OFFICERS
ARE TO DEAL WITH THE MENTALLY
ILL.
JUST EVEN FROM PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE, IT CAN BE HORRIFIC.
I WANT TO SINGLE OUT THE
TECHNOLOGY WORLD.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO CHANGE BLACK
LIVES IN THE UNITED STATES,
YOU’VE GOT TO BASICALLY INCREASE
PROSPERITY.
MORE JOB SECURITY, MORE WEALTH.
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT FINANCIALLY
VULNERABLE IN ECONOMIC DOWNTURN,
THE ECONOMIC RATE TRIPLE FROM
FEBRUARY TO MAY.
I’M GOING TO CALL OUT APPLE AND
TIM COOK, BECAUSE HE’S ALWAYS
VERY QUICK TO QUOTE
DR. MARTIN LUTHER KING JR. IN
RESPONSE TO GEORGE FLOYD’S
DEATH.
HERE’S WHERE THE APPLE STATS
WERE AND JUST A COUPLE YEARS AGO
IN 2018.
A PERCENTAGE OF AMERICA, 13% OF
THE U.S. POPULATION IS BLACK.
U.S. APPLE EMPLOYEES OVERALL 9%.
IN JUST TECHNOLOGY JOBS, 6%.
LEADERSHIP, 3%.
LOOK AT GOOGLE.
THEY WANT TO TELL YOU WHAT TO
DO.
HOW ABOUT GOING INTO HIGH
SCHOOLS AND HIRING YOUNG BLACK
PEOPLE AND TRAINING THEM IN
AREAS WHERE THERE AREN’T
OPPORTUNITIES.
AT GOOGLE, LESS THAN 4% OF THE
WORKFORCE ARE BLACK AMERICANS.
LEADERSHIP, UNDER 3%.
THAT IS DISGRACEFUL.
STOP TALKING, START WALKING.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, JESSE,
LAST WORD.
CAN THE MEDIA CHANGE ITSELF?
CAN IT POLICE ITSELF?
>> Jesse: GREG, AS AN EXPERT
IN HUMAN BEHAVIOR AND GROUP
PSYCHOLOGY AND AS A SEASONED
VETERAN OF THE POLITICAL
COMMENTARY AND MEDIA ANALYSIS, I
WOULD SAY THAT PEOPLE JUST CAN’T
BE PERSUADED WITH FACTS AND
LOGIC AND STATISTICS.
THIS COUNTRY IS RUN BY FEELINGS.
I MEAN, YOU CAN LOOK AT THE
RUSSIA THING.
PEOPLE STILL THINK THAT TRUMP IS
A RUSSIAN SPY, EVEN AFTER THREE
YEARS OF US POINTING OUT THAT’S
FALSE.
YOU’RE NOT GOING TO CHANGE
PEOPLE’S MINDS WITH ALL YOUR
BEAUTIFUL LOGIC.
IT’S GOT TO BE DONE THROUGH
FEELING.
A MAJORITY OF THE COUNTRY FEELS
LIKE THIS IS A RACIST COUNTRY
AND THERE’S RACIST POLICE
BRUTALIZING BLACK AMERICA, WELL
THEN THOSE FEELINGS BECOME A
REALITY.
SO, UNFORTUNATELY YOU ARE JUST
GOING TO HAVE TO CHANGE PEOPLE’S
PERCEPTIONS AND FEELINGS BECAUSE
THEN WE CAN FIGURE OUT THE FACTS
LATER, BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT